oh god damn it
Kirk why don't I keep hurting myself as
of the game is Gabe ah
god
[ __ ] yeah dude oh thank you thank you
ah
okay I'm tired now hello everybody my
name is markiplier and welcome to the
sequel to with the addition of
markiplier you remember this is the fan
game that I played about two weeks ago
now high fly sis's yeah hits six million
subscribers good man you'll be good for
reading playing on a fair game this is
so huh brave content Oh
I'm God yeah I'm out of shape here for a
second
give me a minute I'm like one of the
game characters that they spread it for
two seconds British kind of cool that I
did actually oh they're all gamers oh
okay that's what they can always print a
beauty their time okay so let's get
started now that I got a breather
which might be able to determine how
long it was depending on how music
looped how many times you do this okay
let's try some of this oh darn it puffs
but died who is puff but I suppose
that's enough asses and angels for one
day that's the name of the game actually
oh and as always I'll see you not the
end don't go please don't leave me
thanks for you bye bye but don't leave
me okay that was just what he would know
stop it don't leave don't leave let him
it's not over yet with you this Oh Oh
back again yeah yeah I guess
man the developer like knows exactly
what I'm gonna do at all times it's
really weird I don't have to dance no
more oh thank goodness
oh I'm so tired have any wanna dance
anymore
oh that's right all my friends are
coming around today for a priority I
should probably get everything ready in
the kitchen and let me put this out of
my pocket I'm not wearing pants or
anything okay
all right what whoa was this the outfit
I was wearing before okay it's a manual
from earthbound that was a great manual
it had scratch-and-sniff stuff in the
back press X to bring up the menu use
this read certain items that doesn't
sound right this is amazing already I
love it tiny bug stem hello mark
I know kill me bro what uh don't you
remember you tried to turn me into jelly
then I killed you mark there's more than
one type of likes Tim in the world I'm
just one of many okay so you're all good
or am i ah just kidding haha I thought
you loved that face mark what no this is
creepiest freddy fazbears balls uh let a
doc your memory mark oh I know
Wow okay oh that that is an awesome tiny
box am I gonna say that right now I was
like handsome Squidward mixed with mr.
Popo I love it what I totally forgot
about that what the hell was that a
vision mark me tiny box sims will help
you along with them that's awfully nice
of you house heard something at the end
there though oh yeah I have no idea what
caused that neither does the developer
why nothing nothing okay oh that's so
cute I totally forgot that was that
garfield without garfield is kind of
boring no it's not sure Ralph
lots of ugh so here's a nice one ahem
spelling your guide on how to not look
like a dumbass oh here we go intense and
purpose gee I wonder if this book would
have come in handy before no probably
not the length of the frappe whole necro
strip is determined by the four distinct
squats needed to bend the material babe
what
it's table simply amazing look at his
smooth and polished shine
I think there's developers just a little
more sarcastic than the last game
incredible I say old chap apparently my
tank bed wasn't manly enough oh I think
this guy listen to some of the comments
I'll take change the game accordingly
it's my teddy bear well also listen to
mine Big Bear Barney it's my diary
he'll markiplier today I learned I can
sprint by holding down shift key those
angel butts are mine
oh I didn't know if you did I not do
that before I forget eating fruit is rad
kids good box ah doesn't have the thing
ringing boxes despite what anyone else
says this is a throne a cheap one but
still a throne it's still weird again
because my facial expressions are
exactly the same is in the bottom
sometimes like if this is this wrong of
me to play this game you see that shield
up there I got it after I fought a bear
of course it was a human in a bear suit
but still a bear I remember that that
was from Marga Byers man time not like
that not like that at all so manly
sometimes I even surprise myself this is
the most manly thing I own are you
getting sick of the word manly yet I
doubt anyone is okay unless I need
something I won't be heading into the
Attic just yet well who are you to tell
me what I need to do game developer no
throw up invisible walls for me
oh this much better than before I have a
very pristine house good for me
smells good smells so good I wonder if
anyone else thinks I'm a pansy get it
pansy
no I don't get it no shut up I don't get
it bars of gold from dungeon nightmares
oh that's where I collect all the gap
like it what if horror games you
actually played and you have to keep
this stuff that you were in there then
you die so what if horror games were
real life never mind jewel from
apparition within the we're IFFT god I
wish I got to keep all that stuff
flowers do really live it up home what
is this my mail well it seems that
everyone is RSVP'd oh crap the party
starts in 10 minutes I gotta go get the
drinks good wait I got it I got a look
at everything wow it's hard Bob LA live
it seemed to have fascinating flowers
but you'll probably see otherwise no I
not have a fascination with flowers is
that my cue me I don't know if I'll be
able to be talking to be revived food to
be talking to you this plant doesn't
even have powers what a waste
tiny back SIM notes from the castle on
one of these things it just says a gue
over and over I wonder what it means I
wonder to me crazy more fruit fruit is
off the hook yo an apple a day keeps the
doctor away unless you sniffle you're
allergic to apples in which you probably
shouldn't eat them this guy is so funny
it's ridiculous pizza I sure up chica
doesn't show up ooh
radical soda this is have an itty-bitty
[ __ ] oh okay so I'm definitely gonna
break up my safe this time and I hope
the yamimash is still dead for some
reason now I'm sick of flowers no I'm
not you know get really hard to say new
things about flowers oh I didn't check
the clock in the wall why am i outside
now and why does the music change to
something with a little more ominous who
knows that yamimash is grave oh oh it's
tiny like Sims grave okay if you're
wondering I made a cross music parts of
him
why rusted pieces but you just said hide
a tiny box Tim oh oh potato it's my
potato song from seven days to die
that's crazy you want to make me murder
potato potato
I'm gonna kill you dead run Wade run
Wade run away from me
that's so long ago geez cabbage or
lettuce who cares oh no I have no idea
what this plant is but it looks tasty
turnips that's all I have to say about
that okey can I walk out on this I wrote
a poem for tiny box in hmmm tiny box Tim
you catered to my every whim I never
thought of your fields when I made you
kill people in happy wheels you now rest
under the grass soon you will be uh
touching my that's this how could I do
that okay that's it alright the
horrifying forest of doom sounds fun
what looks up close to this thing
oh what a great stuff I have such a
positive outlook on life I do I'm very
happy with my life it's ten to seven
okay so I needed to go get a drink hang
on let me just blow my whistle game was
just filled to the brim every single
sound effect was just a reflection of
some soundbite from my playthroughs way
in the past and thousand dishtowels blah
blah blah here's half empty let's see
marvelous a cornucopia fruit I dare say
to be in the hotel with healthy meals
broccoli a whole I know what that means
I love me some grapes not but beggars
debris read and seriously here's the
word rat again I did oh no there will be
plenty of foods for the guests I'm sure
okay so what is this party for
well the soda is here but where's the
beer maybe it's in the Attic
okay so now I get to go to the Attic to
chopping board meat of course I'll leave
the meat yeah let's have some bacon mmm
salmonella
uncooked bacon yeah stop
red bag iPod that's green Jeff various
Cubs in plates oh man this game is just
a delight this game is just wait tonight
wait did I look at everything
yeah let's make sure it's pot of tea a
pot of tea
okay what's that from Tea Party
simulator I'm not sure I don't know what
everything is referring to anymore
doctor the cure is the bathroom where
I'm probably gonna get stabbed in the
butt as long as the hood [ __ ] my pants
I'll be fine there's so many game
references so many oh I wanted to
interact with the mirror reading
material for when I'm on the loo that's
a lot reading to my new hot tub okay all
apparently I also keep plants in my
bathroom it oxygenates
the outside there are towels in here Wow
what do you know I'm right you see I
live here so I know what's inside okay
smartass let's just go get the beer cuz
I think I've explored every single thing
in this damn house uh hang on let me
just save first Oh God
it's too funny alright anyway continuing
on going up to the attic does for some
reason I keep beer in the attic Oh
what's all this in in memory
oh no I keep that in my attic what a
weirdo I am Oh
someone has carved the word but into
this bench it was me oh I'm such a sassy
sue
he's our mine oh well the more sex I
have the better alrighty then it's a
bucket there's a spider in this box I
hope he doesn't explode oh that's a
reference to ball boy gifts my fan send
me wish I could get through it all and
thank each person individually because
that's the mark of our spirit I wish I
could all right it's my wine collection
yes it's all red wine let's say your
wine collection is smaller than mine
that's not the only thing that's smaller
than mine ha wait what you don't like
these jokes whit wine I'm not that bad
everybody am i I'm not some Florida
ancient material all the way from tiny
box Tim's mansion ok
my amazing Spears yes I do keeps warts
in my attic don't you I don't even have
an attic no one knows about these I can
trust you not to tell anyone right Who
am I talking to
am I talking to me
darn it empty MD MD MD MD MD empty that
piano playing by itself
oh yes the designer that's great is
acquitted boxer he knows oh do I live
back
it's my piano can't remember how the
hell I got up here yeah me neither
helmet in case I ever need it suit of
armor I would look so badass in this
good thing finally some beer let's get
back downstairs
did I grab it still plenty left okay
fine I got it then
oh no y'all be bad no I can't even look
at it anymore absorbed his head him died
my wings didn't go over the gap I never
found out what the sparkly do was in
there they're here are you guys ready to
party
okay the music's just gonna loop over
and over again
Oh Danny oh my god Danny
hey Markie moon damn it Danny how are
you so sexy Shh well of course I tell
Danny's sexy right to his face I don't
really care who knows Danny is a sexy
bastard god I wish I was that handsome
anyway oh hey Mark what a party huh glad
you liked it Burt who are you Wade Oh
jontron oh hey Mark why are great but
thats not jontron present Owen give you
a little something a cat costume yeah I
was uh giving it by fan uh thanks shall
I put up why would I put on the cat
costume I didn't even get to save all
right fine now I'm pretty I'm a I'm a
pretty little kitty hello everybody and
welcome to the pretty little kitty
podcast glad you liked it
okay I'm just gonna go over here with my
pretty a2b2 kitty claws and I'm like
dance around like a pretty
and then I'm gonna nice and funny
whenever whatever shut up I don't know
I'm just acting like the pretty little
bit of kitty that jontron made me to be
for some reason whether Doritos at mark
I didn't buy any weight oh but you have
plenty left over seems to be impossible
to step over the pig roast I may never
get to my back into my bathroom again
bang Digga Raptor LD mark boy I sure I'm
tired I think I had too much soda and
that's beer I don't even
hi mark that's radical soda by the way
uh hi did I wait you what doc I guess
the party's just getting started
oh hey what the hell seems like the
sound is coming from the Attic
wait what hmm what's happening mark
where's that noise coming from I just
said where I was coming from Wade hey
Wade I would run right now but I'm too
full I'm a sexy will baby well if you
need help moving just ask I'm free to uh
lend a hand
why is this guy shipping me with Danny
why don't I mind yeah I'm good yeah I'm
good
anyway this looks like the start of a
bad game if ever I've ever seen
thanks John it thanks John [ __ ] all
over radical soda game even though
radicals automate everything here the
clock stopped that's Wade's voice well
here we go I can't go anywhere else but
upstairs so I might as well just go for
it
oh this got decrepid who could have done
such a thing I don't know what what's
going on here it's so weird somebody's
carved the word but I already knew that
oh no my gift for my fans of burning you
know who's blame up here who are you
here's a girl see on Venus hey you sub
what are you doing it just because screw
your piano oh hi you me what did I do
parade howdy my sim want to help me on
this one boy seconds from downstairs
cheers a mark
hello baby what you doing with your
clothes on baby what I said that was
inappropriate wait that was you it was a
joke and oh by the way have you gotten
more squat what
oh so shorter okay silence EEP you will
be punished for your perverted death
uh hi hey Marcos bunny hi jontron you're
about to die aren't you nope all that's
wise very wise John I'm not doing it
goodbye uh so could I go silence
you'll be sent to hell why okay that's
why John right now knocks wait over on
the head - your friends are persistent
markiplier this one can join you in hell
oh but I'm not here to help mark Bob I'm
here to help you Oh glorious and
intelligent angel Bob you're also seems
implausible why would you betray your
friend marts always putting me second he
even picked Wade over me I didn't mean
to it was an accident
it was an accident Bob it was an
accident
it was my quick thinking that got me out
of that sticky situation but Bob I
didn't mean it I would never big weight
over you you're a voice from downstairs
hey no what I mean is I couldn't pick
between both of you but you did mark and
it was the wrong choice
uh-huh prepare to enter prepare to enter
hell Magua here god this game is awesome
is Mari that's amazing
oh I think I think he nailed it yay
jack-jack top of the mortgage here mark
I stepped all over your body in the
first game now here in hell that's
awesome
but but you were dead does this mean I'm
in Hell what you think a bad enough to
go to hell this is the spirit world
where some dead
you don't look at Marquee boo oh this
means I could finally get out of here
hey what do you mean in order to get out
of the spirit world one needs a living
host to open the portal because we dead
people can't actually taught anything oh
I get it like a ghost let's go to to get
to the portal jack join the party
yay my god Jack with me we're gonna jack
it all around town me and Jack together
forever as one we're gonna go jacking
around corners marking jacking around
the portal we're gonna touch the portal
mark and Jack together and then we're
gonna Jack I can't think of any more
jokes okay mark who told you I can't
talk to anything
my body just goes right through it you
don't ever wanna meet the man who cut
down that tree you didn't have a face
you got the feeling I already met him
maybe possibly mmm so where am I
supposed to go Jack you poo am I
supposed to do a Jackie boy I've never
seen this soda street before it's a
dread tree mark don't look him for trees
stop being such a blonde idiot mark but
there's no denying accent but I don't
care oh I can't wait to be loved again
well we aren't carried quite there yet
keep your eyes peeled you by the name of
Bob yes my queen if I am to take over
this dimension I will need materials you
will bring them what sort of materials
my queen Bob's a smart one here for now
I will need five red toadstools if you
fail to find them you'll be disemboweled
I will head off it wants my queen oh I
played away about Duane Bobick wait what
hey can I save what a waste of wine how
can I save Oh
prove your loyalty I probably shouldn't
touch that it'd probably send me to hell
see mrs. marks armor there's a nifty
helmet old boxes I wonder what mark
keeps in them nothing just box eyes dude
right thanks okay I can use a drink
right now and by the booms what a waste
of wine looks like a memorial for
yamimash poor look well I meet him in
the spirit world well I
hey I heard something you no need to be
alarmed Tim you you helped kill mark
you're mistaken Tim mark is not dead he
is in the spirit world and I didn't want
to help send him there but it was my
only choice what why you see before the
party started I was reading a book a
book about mythical beings when I went
up into the Attic to see what John was
running from I knew instantly that we
were what we were dealing with was none
other than the fact is a jealous these
creatures are incredibly powerful more
so than even all of us at once could
handle so I knew I had to do something I
had read that even with their great
power these fake angels were quite naive
now that I pretended to hate mark I have
gained her trust thus allowing me time
to research a way to bring mark back and
kill her
that's very smart of you Bob well I
don't use a Dexter skin in Minecraft for
nothing oh thanks Bob I really
appreciate it Mark's computer I better
not touch it I don't spark suppose mark
is any books on mythical creatures
Garfield with a girl sounds Alerus it is
hilarious I wonder what sort of books
mark keep in here oh um yuck I should
confiscate these thanks Bob
thanks for stealing all my corn not that
I have piles of porn lying everywhere
Oh huh uh-huh anyway are you keeping
something from us no not at all Bob but
what are you talking about some sort of
teddy bear dear mark a liar this party
is going to be the best all of my
friends will be there
well my living friends anyway
a I hope you're okay mark do you do you
Bob
apples why does mark keep apples in his
room box sixes what a tiny chair it's a
throne blah-blah-blah open menu with
axes Allah Oh that still makes me
chuckle in charl i remember this this is
what after mark wrestled that guy in a
bear suit yeah it's a bit dangerous to
keep knives on your wall this is a
hideous shade of pink hey screw you Bob
is everyone still at the party oh hi
Wade
Bob where's Mark what's happening up
there Wade there's no time to explain
you got to get out of what is taking so
long oh nothing nothing my queen just
escorting this salesman out of the house
kill him uh yeah there's really no
reason to kill kill him or I will kill
both of you do not fake it I will
torture each one of you with pleasure
what wait what but Bob I'm so sorry Wade
the world oh this is so sad but I know
it's a trick Bob smart enough he won't
get tricked by that he won't get led
astray into that he he'll find a way out
of this I know Bob well okay so that's
all the time I have for this episode I
know there's gonna be a bit longer
because apparently there's four endings
so I gotta see through to all of them
eventually Ben I will or at least I will
try my best so either way thank you all
so much for watching I will finish this
up in another episode Thank You radical
soda for making it it's a lot of fun so
far it's so cool to see all these things
in thank you everybody so much for 6
million subscribers thank you for being
with me so like so long like in the
almost 3 years that I've been doing this
now and you know if you haven't checked
on my vlog that the pursuit of happiness
vlog I said a lot of really cool things
or not really cool things I'm not trying
to brag about myself still but like I
said a lot of things that were on my
mind and I
think they were profound and I think
they were meaningful and I hope you guys
take something out of that so if you if
you didn't see already it'll be linked
in the annotation over there in the
description please check it out thank
you so much for being here and thank you
so much for supporting me and believing
me I really do appreciate it I love
these fan games that people have made to
be and eventually I will get to them all
hopefully thank you again everybody so
much for watching and as always I will
see you in the next video bye bye
is that the spoon-feeding happiness it's
nothing getting a baptism it is the fact
that you want something baby hey baby